over the weekend mark german dropped a  huge leak bomb on us concerning apple's  entire 2022 mac lineup so with this last  report from mark i am happy to say that  we finally have the missing piece of the  puzzle that can put a lot of completely  baseless rumors to rest and confirm when  each mac should be coming later this  year so without further ado let's jump  right into it no m2 trip reveal until  the last of the m1 powered max are  released we have the m1 pro and max mac  mini at the event next month potentially  alongside a matching new 27 imac then we  have both the imac pro and the mac pro  at wwdc in june just to finish out the  two-year apple silicon transition then  we've got all of the m2 max at apple's  october event with apple potentially  delaying one or two of them by a month  or two if they don't want to release all  four at once